these Pacific Islands off the coast of
Australia are threatened by rising sea
levels they're at risk of vanishing
because of global warming for these
islands a climate agreement is a matter
of survival this is one of the issues at
cop 23 after Paris and Marrakesh the
bond climate conference in Germany is a
new step towards the implementation of
the climate agreement it's very kind of
hoarse annoying with rusev the first
hour since extreme weekly here it's not
even if I manage to start and I'm
finished I'm Austin Ariza up from Austin
does the rest of it to Zalman hurt
despite Donald Trump's decision to
withdraw from the Paris deal MEP s
demand that the Paris agreements limit
of two degrees Celsius on a global rise
in temperature is not only implemented
but also revised to 1.5 degrees
vt hisses so nice my kind would switch
to Etzion murphy like Glinka salsa
Graham it under and Parton and Messina
Canada Japan and Rita furnace Omaha and
the Americana done via enca bentonville
9 under the yoke elin with averted eyes
the European Parliament calls for a
European strategy to eliminate emissions
by 2050 among the objectives to remove
incentives for fossil fuels lawmakers
also want more international
coordination to avoid relocating
polluting industries outside the EU
[Music]